when people say they summit for the view
I think they're missing a lot of the
equation of why we do the things we do
the summit honestly is pretty
anticlimactic the movement is for me the
most exciting part my name is Eric Wymer
and I'm the first blind person to have
climbed the tallest peak in every
continent
[Music]
when I was four or five years old I was
diagnosed with this incredibly rare
disease called retinas jeesus it
attacked my retinas and essentially
unravel them
when I finally went blind it was a weird
relief like the worst thing had happened
so there's nothing else to lose
there was a recreational group taking
blind kids rock climbing and that was it
for me it was sort of the full package
of adventure all the things I thought I
wouldn't have as a blind person they
made 14 for this pitch yeah I'm counting
them right now okay when I get on to a
rock face I actually feel like I'm in my
element the things that sighted people
learn to do with their eyes I've learned
to do with my hands
when I'm clipping a bolt to a carabiner
I'm feeling it I'm making sure it's
correctly clipped and if I fall that
that carabiner is gonna hold me
[Music]
I can't look up the rock and see the
holds and plan a big route I can only
see as far as my hands
it's breathtakingly exciting sometimes
you hear those cars way down below you
in the floor of the canyon
I love that sound of emptiness a lot of
external stuff sort of disappears and
you're thinking about nothing but that
next hold in front of you
so it's very very meditative very much
kind of like an inner mind sport I like
that I think that's the best pitch could
you feel that space like the exposure
down there yeah I mean especially with
these trucks flying by down there you
kind of echoes through the whole canyon
and you can hear everything yeah what do
you say we top out yeah let's um it's
right up here right yeah okay
as a blind climber it's really hard and
you just sort of have to embrace that
suffering
blindness is just a thing that happened
to me I think like all adversities we
got'em use them as a catalyst to push
you in new directions it's the idea of
turning bad things into good things and
it's something I think we all could use